you've uh you've studied a lot of people
who lie who defraud
uh cheat and scam
on a basic human level
um how do you have trouble trusting
human beings in your own life
uh how what's your relationship with
trust of other humans it's a great
question so funny enough before I did
this I was like an incorrigible Optimist
I
everything the sun shined every witch
place
um I always saw like everybody is
fundamentally good nobody was bad it
just was like sort of that wrong place
wrong time bad incentives
that view has darkened significantly uh
but I just try to remember remember my
sample set and just like I'm just
sampling sort of the worst and uh I try
not to let it bleed into my
day-to-day life and I think I've I think
it's probably because I was such an
optimist early on that I've I've been
able to kind of retain some of it I call
it enlightened optimism like choosing to
be optimistic in the face of
a realistic sense of the problems in the
world and with a realistic sense of like
the scale and the challenge ahead
um I I actually think it's much braver
to be an optimist
when you're aware of what's going on in
the world than to be a cynic I think
being a complete cynic is maybe I'm not
saying it's wrong but I'm saying it's
maybe the easier way just mentally to
cope with so much negativity it's like
just saying well it's all bad it's all
doomed to fail it's all going to go bust
is
easier
yeah that leap into a believing that's a
good world is um
it's a little it's a little baby Act of
Courage
at least I think so
I don't think it's naive
no it can be some people are naive that
are optimistic but but oftentimes
um just because someone's optimistic
does not mean they're naive they could
be full well aware of how troubling the
world is
and I also believe some of the people
you study
you know I'm a big believer that all of
us are capable of Good and Evil
um
so in some sense the people you study
are just uh the successful ones
the ones who uh
chose sort of the dark path and were
successful at it and I think all of us
can choose the dark path in life
um
it's uh that's like the
that's the responsibility we all carry
is we get to choose that at every every
moment and it's like a big
responsibility
and it's a chance to really have
integrity it is a chance to stand for
something good in this world and all of
us have that because I think all of us
are capable of you all of us could be
good Germans all of us could in
atrocities uh be part of the atrocities
yeah I think it's
I really have um especially in recent
years tried to
somewhat de-personalize my work and
um
see it almost like as like a I don't
know like a force of nature that I'm
fighting more than like individuals
because of this exact thing I think like
sort of therefore but the grace of God
their GOI is kind of a really profound
way to understand yourself
rather than is just like fundamentally
good and like and full of Integrity
acknowledging that so much of that is a
product of your environment and your
family and your upbringing
and so much of the people who don't have
that is a product of their environment
it doesn't absolve them but it gives you
more perspective
to tr like to sort of deal fairly if
that makes sense and not approach it
from a place of anger or a place of
outrage there is a sense of like sadness
for the victims there's a sense of
outrage for the victims but approach the
individual who's done the thing
from that
place of understanding of this isn't
just this person there's like a whole
broader thing going on here